meagan Marco is serving the community by
cooking up comfort food
together is a cookbook but it's also the
story of a West London community who
gathered together in a kitchen and
discovered the healing power of sharing
of food on Monday the Dutchess of Sussex
announced her support for the new
charity cookbook together our community
cookbook featuring 50 recipes from women
affected by the fatal grin felt our fire
last June I feel very excited that for
my own unique recipe so it going to be
used to run the world because some of
the recipes that I put in there are
actually like very unique to my family
Meghan joined the survivors in private
this past summer to hear their inspiring
stories and help cook at the hub
community kitchen all proceeds from the
cookbook will help support the kitchen
after settling into her life in London
as a Royal Prince Harry's wife revealed
she secretly visited the mosque back in
January quote on my first visit I acts
mean I heard the resident chef de
cuisine so to speak how I could help
adding an apron was quickly wrapped
around me I pushed up my sleeves and
found myself washing the rice for lunch
when the 37 year old wasn't getting her
hands dirty in the kitchen she was
writing the foreword for the book
calling the hub community kitchen quote
a place for women to laugh grieve cry
and cook together I immediately felt
connected to this community kitchen like
these women I'm passionate about food
and cooking as a way of strengthening
communities
[Music]